i'm here with my trusty co-pilot ross
matthews and we love
talking to everyone in the audience so
if it's okay we'd like to take some of
your questions and something we called
drew and a hey all right
okay
who is up first um
nicole where's nicole she's like there
you go nicole you have a question about
beauty right yes i do hi drew and ross
hi
nice to meet you guys
i'm 44 and i'm beginning to realize that
my beauty routine from the 20s and 30s
is not working anymore
so i was hoping you could give me some
uh tips on how to best cover the new
bags under my eyes and the brown spots
on my face that i've had from too many
years of having too much fun in the sun
well for starters i got to say you look
good nicole you look great thank you
yeah
yeah um do you find that you want to
attack puffiness or color
uh more puffiness
okay um you have to get these eye
patches they will blow your mind they're
from a brand called talika t-a-l-i-k-a
you can use them three times in a row
and then you dispose them you put them
on your eye for 30 minutes
puff be gone and i mean for the rest of
the day
and for dark circles i really like some
of the olay products okay they really
help with color
and i would say too if you're going to
mix up the routine of makeup play at
home right play look in the mirror take
some selfies before you test drive it
out in the real world all right yes
definitely okay good
and keep doing what you're doing because
like i said girl you look good thank you
so much thank you
all right our next question is from
janice janice what's your question hi
janice hi drew hi ross hi my question is
this first my husband and i we are empty
nesters but there's one problem my kids
moved out and they left the cat behind
so now i don't feel like i should be
taking care of anything at this point in
time my life
what can i do
to get rid of this furry family member
that they left behind that's my question
oh wow anyone here want to adopt a cat
yeah anyone looking for a kitty
no okay i really don't want to get you
know remove her from the family all
together but i'd like for them to come
back and pick her up take her you know
this this could be a teaching moment for
is it your son's cat
yes yeah to sort of say hey
big boy
you got the cat now you got to help find
me a loving home for this cat to go to
or maybe not permanently but just when
you go on vacation i would say make your
son do all the work it's his kitty cat
okay how far away is he
uh he's in jersey that's not far no why
doesn't he take the cat well he can't
have cats in his uh
his dorm he's in college
yes and the other family members they
can't have cats either in their you know
apartment complex so i hate to say it
janice but i think you better get used
to that yeah
i would
make friends thank you thank you
[Music]
i i think you're
stuck for the next few years and i
hopefully it'll live long enough and as
soon as he's out of that dorm guess what
bye-bye bye-bye
that could be his graduation gifts
here's your cat back yeah all right
thank you thank you
sorry janice
all right and our last question comes
from twitter the marvelous mrs mabel
tweeted us cute name cute right she says
we just returned back to the office and
someone keeps stealing my lunch out of
the refrigerator oh my god i hate that
how do i catch the culprit this would
drive me insane drew
um i literally want to take that person
and just
give them a piece of my mind right i do
who does that bad people do that bad
people son of a you know why well i do
know what and i also know what you
should do all right i'm assuming it's a
man i don't know why but really
no and i don't mean like i was acting
like it was a man maybe it's a woman
whoever you are
how dare you how dare you and but mrs
mabel here's here's what she needs a
solution i have a solution for you all
right prepare your lunch tomorrow but
mix in some exlax
okay leave it in the fridge and that
will be the last time they steal your
lunch all right
there you go
problem
problem solved that is
ross
does that who steals someone else's
lunch
we don't like you you're gonna end up in
the bathroom for hours
and think about what you did
also janice i know a litter box that's
gonna change your life oh my god jack
because we're still on you because i
have four cats i have four rescue cats
and i've tried every litter box on the
planet and there's only one that really
does it for me so i'm gonna get you the
make and model of that we got eye
patches kitty litters and xlax today
we hope he helped i hope we were able to
help you guys out we love answering your
questions
[Music]
you